if you can follow the instructions here
you should eventually be able to fall
asleep within 10 to 15 minutes of going
to bed first you must limit your
caffeine consumption and only drink
caffeinated products before noon the
second thing you have to do in order to
fall asleep easily is to control your
lighting when Blue Light which is the
same bright white light that's emitted
from most of our devices reaches our
eyes it prevents our bodies from
producing melatonin it's basically
tricking our body into thinking that
it's still the morning there are certain
light bulbs that you can get that are
blue light free the light they produce
feels similar to the lighting of candles
and this will help your body produce
more melatonin in the evening now the
third and final thing you have to do to
fall asleep easily is to lower your body
temperature you can turn on a fan or an
air conditioner which will help lower
your body temperature or if you don't
want to use so much electricity you can
opt to take a shower in the evening the
ideal time to take a shower is around
two hours before you plan on heading to
bed